here in the middle of Germany the wooded
hills of the Hynek region extend over an
area of 160 square kilometers high up in
the trees the canopy walkway offers a
unique perspective on the broadleaf
forest
more than 360,000 visitors come to the
Hynek national park each year it really
works it's amazing to see how many
different kinds of trees there are here
we tend to forget that I really like it
here
you feel like you're right in the midst
of nature on top of it but in it all the
same I love the countryside and this
makes it look really great
mmm Vince it was okay and then the
trouble yes was on I shouldn't damage
that yes it's beautiful here
especially in the sunshine like today
yeah and the really special thing is
that so high up here the path is still
wheelchair accessible
for centuries large parts of the Hynek
were used for forestry and more recently
it housed a military training area for
decades before being turned into a
national park in 1997 since then the
core area has been reverting to primeval
forests nature is being left alone it's
teaming I'm up here we've got a dead
fallen tree dead wood is full of life
that is a slogan and we can see how true
it is eating the torta this dead wood
trunk is covered with moss but there's
something else looking out a fungus that
specializes in decaying hardwood it's
called the stats horn fungus and there
is a whole range of funguses and insects
as well but live off dead wood so it's
important to have four structures like
here in the Hynek National Park to offer
these species a habitat when woods in
Central Europe are left to their own
devices they usually turn into beech
forests the beech trees compete
successfully for the sunlight that
ensures their growth
when memens E&E before imagine that it's
foggy which it sometimes is and when you
look at the forest structure in the
background you can imagine it as a
typical german forest were all those
fairytales originated the woods also
magical in the springtime when wild
garlic and early flowering plants and
trees adorn the forest floor or in the
autumn with its bright foliage in 2011
the frost was added to the UNESCO World
Heritage List at the National Park
Center in teens burg visitors can learn
all about the ecology of the first
habitat
a big attraction and the National Park
are the Wildcats around 30 of them live
and Hainish visitors won't usually
encounter the shy animals in the wild
but they can't see them in the Wildcat
village in Hojo order
environmentalists have come up with an
ingenious means to encourage Wildcats to
settle in forests throughout Germany
they've built protected corridors
connecting the wooded areas Jesus to
Qumran shaft in the Indian Deutschland
Germany's fragmented landscape gives the
animals little chance of surviving
long-term this project with the
corridors is trying to enable these wild
animals a chance to move around again in
Germany I found this Afghan [ __ ]
the Heineken National Park has all the
conditions that can make it a paradise
for wild cats as the forest is growing
bigger every day